[Applaudissements]
la skieuse de geneviève simard avait 12
ans lorsqu'elle a été agressée
sexuellement pour la première fois par
l'entraîneur bertrand charest qui a été
reconnu coupable en 2010 est d'avoir
commis des crimes sexuels sur neuf
victimes entre 1991 et 1998 mon enfance
a été volé
le ski était
ce qui était ma passion
cinq ans après l'incarcération de son
agresseur l'ancien athlète olympique que
se réjouir ottawa s'attarde à cette
crise qui touche année après année de
nombreuses disciplines sportives au
canada avec cette annonce le
des critères très spécifique pour avoir
droit au financement pioncer sport au
canada on est vraiment lié très
directement au financement fédéral et
provincial à compter d'avril 2023 sport
canada pourra exiger des fédérations
sportives de remplir certaines
conditions en matière d'imputabilité ou
de bonne gouvernance en échange de
financement une façon de s'attaquer à
cette vague de dénonciations qui
s'apparente au mouvement moi aussi
souligner la ministre des sports si
c'est juste les medal quand on en a peur
qu'on a vécu des mauvaises expériences
pendant le chemin qui nous a menés
jusque là
ça devient juste une expérience négative
c'est à peu près sur le sport
au cours des derniers mois les
allégations concernant des abus sexuels
de la maltraitance ou de la négligence
ont fait surface dans plusieurs
disciplines que ce soit en natation en
gymnastique ou en rugby l'ancien athlète
olympique que jean luc brassard
considère le plan de la ministre
saintonge
comment pas dans la bonne direction
maintenant c'est important aussi que
vraiment les bottines suivent les
babines parce que dans le monde fédérer
sportif c'est les mêmes personnes sont
encore présentes des dispositions pour
rendre le sport plus sécuritaire au
canada afin qu'il se pratique un peu
plus dans la joie ici gabriel proulx
radio canada montréal